hello everybody and welcome to the h3
podcast live welcome and happy Friday
everybody we're so glad to have you you
know
we had originally scheduled for a
furries to join us today to to try to
understand their mystical and wild and
interesting culture that didn't work out
but what we do have is thousands of
dollars worth of furry suits with no
purpose or use for them so here I
present to you me ethan klein in a furry
suit i've got a lot to say about it it's
very uncomfortable and this looks like
the beginning of a snuff film i would
imagine but it's real hot so with that
being said let's get right into the show
ela do you have anything you want to add
to this Eva doesn't talk she's too
kawaii but she's got the moves she's
into it she's ready for a cuddle she's
ready to she's ready to get in that
cuddle mound right ela nope she oh no
she said well guys enough all that let's
go ahead and get started today on the h3
podcast live do we have an intro or
anything - cut - no we don't okay all
right well let's go ahead and a mosey on
in there
[Music]
so guys we've scheduled a furry episode
and all that we have left is thousands
of dollars of fur boots and a story dude
so the suit is actually the mask is so
brutally miserable and it smells like
camera call I said either don't breathe
inside the mask and a miscarriage
seriously I mean the [ __ ] was made in
China we got this [ __ ] on budget I think
it was a thousand or was it a thousand
for both Dan I think it was a thousand
for both suits because usually these
suits I didn't know they cost upwards to
$3,000 for the whole suit really decent
I'm aroused I don't think they weren't
quite a thousand there they were we
aired on the cheaper side yeah we went
cheap that means that you know there's
cancer-causing chemical tight inside you
know they sent fans apparently you're
supposed to rip a fan aside because it
is so warm
and then oh my god it's just miserable I
don't know how you could spend a day in
this thing you know what I I want to
okay well at any rate that's let me let
me get out of this [ __ ] nightmare
I guess say it's really choking like
that takes dedication do they wear it
like all day you're covering my camera I
don't know just okay I'm back
I'm drinking coffee Wow so I wanted to
originally we were scheduled to have
furries on today and I was super excited
about that because I just find the whole
culture so mystifying so confusing so
truly bizarre and strange and so we had
a prominent furry the prominent furry he
was the guy scheduled to come out today
we had booked the hotel in the flight
you know we had bought the suits we were
we were invested but apparently the
furry community is not without its drama
because a lot he was getting a lot of
pressure he was being harassed to cancel
it because apparently I think I'm a I'm
transphobic well the transphobic thing
started from I made a joke about cutting
my penis what was it I made a joke about
cutting my penis my penis touched the
toilet bowl all right so your book
really my tweets or a comedy book yeah
if you have like a coffee table with
like little comedy oh I just got a book
idea I had tweeted out something that
like my penis had touched the toilet
bowl seat yes and now I'm gonna have to
change my gender or something you know
something like that and so they got
angry because they're like gender has
nothing to do with your penis gender see
I was transphobic because just because
you cut your penis off doesn't make you
a woman to which I respond I made the
decision that my new identity was gonna
be as a female oh I said I was gonna
change my name to like Eleanor or
something I cut my dick off and I want
someone to [ __ ] me in my dick my my
empty dick Kavis cavity slot slot whoa
damn you up for it let me sleep on it so
they said I'm transphobic because I made
it cutting my penis joke off and you
know I guess and and there's just so
much to ask about the furry thing but
our body workout it didn't work out he
told us after putting one on I have a
lot more questions now yeah
the truth is that I was coming with open
arms and an open heart I really wanted
to understand them on a on a human level
but now that they've cancer to me last
minute it was just gonna be like
hard-boiled eye on the fridge I'm
kidding it's really not that
I'm not mad I thought it was we just
wanted to have them here and just talk
about it he's fascinated by them much
like Joe Rogan has scientists on exactly
industry professionals hurry in a
fursuit but they can't sold about a
couple days out because he had got he s
the guy was getting so much criticism
and backlash she was it was too much for
him to handle from the Fuhrer community
so on one hand I I don't you know I
totally understand his decision that's
his whole life that's this whole thing
it's just a shame that there was so much
outrage that that he had to cancel and
we should say there were a lot of
furries on twitter and also that emailed
us that were like not all of us feel
this way we're all bummed it's not
happening so even that's true it wasn't
a universal outcry but it's true
yes that's a good point in I did receive
a lot of emails of people wanting to
fill in for him but when that happened I
was like you know what maybe just in
like wait this is way too Syria
you know this is too much for this guy
is getting harassed just for coming on
the podcast so there you go that was a
thousand-dollar gag I hope you guys
enjoyed it
but I I so I'm sure we'll find a good
use for those I mean my goodness if not
when Theodore grows up he's got two
costumes already dude he's gonna [ __ ]
die cancer if we make me wear that
they're [ __ ] so welcome everybody today
free podcast experience happy Friday
everybody on top of the morning to you
I'm Ethan claw
I'm Ethan quad you're hosted with the
beautiful lovely you look live rap laws
around the Palace yeah now before we get
started today with our main topic which
is that so funny so you guys probably
heard about the ad pocalypse 2.0 which I
will explain later
but I came across this this article if
somebody was cutting filthy Frank into
kids apt videos on the kids app for
YouTube of him giving instructions or
him making a joke of saying
and cut it remember kids how's that
remember remember kids sideways for
attention long way for results so some
wise guy was editing that into actual
kids apps videos which is so stupid and
same thing to do but some articles wrote
or some people wrote articles about it
and it's hilarious so we've got a whole
scoop there that you guys will enjoy
along with us but before that you know
I'd like to show you something okay you
are a fan of good people right you have
a strong a feeling a feeling about pizza
you like good pizza you do not [ __ ] with
bad pizza that's true so here I found a
video I'm sorry master a master master
ate a pizza the master of FIFA this is a
Brazilian pizza shop as I understand it
already so if this doesn't make you
hungry I don't know what does
so far so good
yeah leaving that dough pretty well
thank you Dan oh yeah all start I mean
there you have it a little bit of a tear
but yeah we can patch that up not to
worry
minor issue this is the master of feats
that we're talking about though man
that's like the bottom of that that's
not a lot of soy sauce burning on the
hole that's all right oh my god I don't
know what that is that could be look or
is it right it looks like right okay so
right more rice and now illa get excited
why get excited my dude this is really
that alfredo sauce but yeah or is it a
chip I guess it's some sort of cheesy
isn't it looks like mayonnaise in that
Organic I think that's organic and then
some corn out of a can uh-huh on the bra
hand and then let's go on over to the
pizza oven not good at spreading stuff
he's the pizza master not you now here
we will pop it in the pizza oven now
we've got the let's throw a log and the
pizza oven and get it going and next up
let's get some garbage in there some
cardboard to get the point yes the
master had nobody gonna throw up the
deuce what's fascinating
so that's garbage burning and he's
pretty good at spitting that thing on
his finger to by not the bet I mean he's
like yeah he's kind of good at it so the
fascinating thing about this is that
Dee's guy this guy is completely earnest
this is the pizza master yeah
now let's get some more unspecified
garbage in there not a lot either like
that cannot be a lot of heat going on
that was literally just unspecified
garbage he scooped it in with the pizza
tool yeah the people the tool and then
he touches the pizza with it to our
street really I love I mean my goodness
you know and I was thinking as he's
scooping the garbage and then lifting
the pizza with the same tool and turning
the pizza around so frequently how was
the last time you think they cleaned
that thing it doesn't need to reclaim
but it's already got garbage
what are you cleaning I guess he's
scooping it and he's playing with a lot
and I really don't know that he's doing
anything but you got a you got a spin it
to get the heat even right right he's
getting it close to the garbage - I know
the returning garbage this is the pizza
man interesting yeah would you eat that
well wait till you see it before you
decide yeah yeah wait to see it I have a
feeling I would probably have diarrhea
for two weeks if I took a bite of that
you would eat it though you know I would
eat a lot of things I'm not sure I would
I think you got I think if you paid me a
hundred thousand dollars of a ticket but
one little nibble he's just he's
scooping the garbage over to the flame
hmm he's scraping the bottom of the
pizza ovens throwing into the plane
pretty incredible yeah so here we have
it Wow the pizza master himself
yeah it looks kind of good until he
starts cutting the pieces so that's why
you wouldn't eat it yeah my biggest
problem was with the spreading as long
as organic Ally did different cultures
you know yeah speaking of different
cultures we've eaten a lot of street
food and whenever we're in Mexico and
stuff and it has made me sick I think we
were eating oh man you know but it was
so much simpler it was just you saw some
some like Mexican lady and she has like
a dome that's super hot I don't know
what's going on under that DOMA what's
going on and then there's just meat on
it all day yeah that meat his oldest
[ __ ] sure and it's hot and it's just
greasy and black taste bomb yet I did
have diarrhea yeah all the time all the
time like everything food is so good
yeah especially the street food it's
like my favorite yeah I'm like how much
is that taco two cents I was like I'll
take five when you eat that kind of food
you get negative calories because you
mishit it oh yeah you're like man I had
like 20 tacos today but I'm uh I'm at
negative 200 al-aziz it's a good diet
yeah it's a great day
speaking of cultures and different food
you guys know I'm a huge fan of salt Bay
and I just saw this this morning I
really wanted to share it with you guys
you know I have a problem with salt bed
he's all flash he's no substance this
guy is a shitty cook it's freaking
disgusting so here I saw this video
today and I'm like here goes frickin
salt Bay again so have a look
first of all what is this meat okay that
doesn't it doesn't look like appetite
let's just put this on a bun all right
like that thing goes on the bun is
already so insane let's take a vat of
melted cheese way too much way way way
way way too much just because you've
lifted doesn't make it [ __ ] edible
dude that's the meat to freeze like a
little family now one egg on top because
I [ __ ] care
and now the bun on top that's it and now
let's take this steak and drive it like
it's a vampire through it and that's
fine of salt but that's apparently
gourmet cooking worthy of Instagram I
mean that's a nightmare he's trying to
crack the egg I guess but he doesn't
happen so just squeezing it my favorite
part is how he drives a stake through it
like it's a [ __ ] Dracula it was the
the bone right yeah was the ball was the
bone
yeah what's the monk like to do yeah
that's that's the that's what I want and
my smell of my sandwich is a huge bone
you don't you throw it out I love cheese
I love me I love egg I don't find that
to be very appetizing like a new genre
the Instagram cooking it's like it's not
even meant to be eaten by anyone it's
just for the video probably yeah it's
but it doesn't even look appetizing
that's my problem here and and no you
know but when do people following this
is a repo so I haven't seen the original
but usually when I see videos like this
it's like 20 million views and
everybody's going crazy about it
yeah even the caption on that those seem
to be kind of getting down on him a
little bit you see that we're on the
sidebar
yeah the Instagram like the caption the
problem with the world is people can't
stand to see another person enjoying
their life sad ass haters this guy's
supported yellow smashing why are you
hating on salt Bay it's just everyone
he missed the black peppers this guy's
criticizing this stuff for not putting
black pepper on it at the point yeah all
right that's true that's why I'm not
gonna eat it
but my favorite part too was like he
clearly put it like way too much salt
yeah it's like the big it's kosher salt
so it's like wait salt I guess I'm gonna
calm salt bay you can start calling me
salt bay because I do ruin a lot of all
right well that's that just to build
your appetite up oh there's one more
video before we get into the main scoop
here and Ian this is something maybe you
could comment on this video by Kanye
captivated the world what where is this
in I thought he was like in Africa but I
think this might not I think there's
just LA yeah I think it's in Calabasas
that's literally the opposite of Africa
because first of all I'm not I want
everyone to know that's not a racist
statement he was recently in their life
no oh you see bunch of black people used
to zoom it's Africa Ethan Ian was it
racist of me to assume they're in Africa
well no we covered that he was in Uganda
thank you so tell me what's going on
here before we watch me and set this up
he's been hosting this Kanye church
every Sunday for the last this is the
first outdoors one all the other ones
were inside mm-hmm
now was this improvised is that what's
going on they're just having a jam sesh
I think a part of it yeah I mean they
have a setlist that they've been running
through of about like 15 songs and this
is a choir that performs with him and
and there's people in the audience I
assume who are recording it yeah there's
the crowd okay that makes sense
so here without further ado this is the
oh yeah oh it doesn't be stuck in your
head all day all day all day all day
I love this video just got a power
stance is he just playing like one
simple chord that's how you get for it
the god thing look how much fun they're
having good so there's the classic one
they're not your autoplay thank you God
why don't I turn that off like decades
ago there's this classic this classic
line now they will be stuck we'll be in
it live in infamy with poopy snoopy
which is Dada Dada yeah so in I love Ian
told me he's like when I saw this I had
to pull over because you know it Ian's
our resident Kanye superfan it was such
a spiritual moment so he was like
somebody sent in this video and he was
like oh why don't you why don't you tell
us what happened was a a stoplight and
then I got the video and I saw just like
a second and I got so overcome with this
emotional connection that I had to get
off the road mmm and how many was
dangerous so you pulled over and how
many times did you watch it probably at
least 10 to 15 are you kidding or is
that serious I watched it a lot yeah
I've been watching it a lot I love this
video the song I got that gut again you
know there's this great I've heard this
told my black comedians I don't know who
but it's so true you can see it's
evident here everyone's like what are
you gonna say no in church black people
they like to celebrate life you see
they're like singing and guy got like
God hear that [ __ ] right no choice but
then white people in church are like
Christ or they awkwardly watch the I
Love You Jesus dude for like 20 minutes
right all right well that's see that
guys showing real love to God and then
the white people they don't have the
balls to show that
a real loving jubilance they just watch
lame love you got what was it I Love You
Jesus whose course love you good so I
find that interesting
black people give it up they raise the
roof for Jesus but white people they're
just buttoned up they just it looks so
boring when white people go to church
yeah yeah yeah and is that racist of
Muta Center I can't comment on Ian you
okay well that's a bad sign Ian's are
not giving me the pass I'm in trouble
no I what I'm what I'm trying to say is
I got a gun all right let's get into it
enough for the deli darling it's almost
time for a break
mmm-hmm in that case let's just watch
one more video that done went by fast
there's a there's have another one I
wanted to show you guys you know you
might enjoy this one as I have a golfer
I always wondered about this there's I
feel like you've got to be kind of a
psycho to stand this close to a golfer
because I've been driving before and
every time I hit the ball I how do you
call that yeah slice it off like yeah
and it's so dead it feels so dangerous
and so scary like I'll be at the driving
range and I'm afraid I'm gonna slice the
dude next to me like somehow it seems
like a rare talent that you can actually
slice it at a 90-degree angle
sideways to you what are you saying did
that happen to you no no but like okay I
feel like every time I hit it it's so
close to hitting somebody so I go well
they're professionals so they don't
slice you know these are real
professionals so everyone is standing
there so confidently as a as a small
plastic balls hit like at 200 miles per
hour I mean this is not this is no joke
so here's the answer to that question
oh right into the at the shin level I
mean that'll break your leg right so
here's where this gets nuts same lady
she doesn't apologize she doesn't
acknowledge what happened yeah slice it
right at the shin back to number two
she's like lady I didn't ask you to
stand there so number two
same lady she hit the same lady twice
it's so loud it sounds so painful oh
it's brutal and it's like a point break
it another lady who gets it she goes
make her cut it out as if like she's
doing it intentionally to man oh no we
didn't oh my goodness thank you to me
undies and ring by the way thank you to
me undies and ring ring ring ring ring
me and ease thank you to Eric and the
chatter just typed me undies and that's
why I thought about it oh oh
Thank You Erica dude oh man Eric thank
you to our gracious sponsors me on DS
undies undies and ring ring we gotta get
you that in fact yeah we do so like what
so much is dead inside I think she's
lost the world away
he doesn't say anything hey there first
aid on the way I'm assuming she's a
professional otherwise why would so many
people be watching her but I I just find
this so peculiar that this could happen
I think I don't necessarily think it
could break a bone although I guess you
got hit in the head dude you could
definitely kill somebody I think with
that I'm not even if you hit him in the
temple or something I you could break a
leg with that that ball is so hard and
it they hit it's so fast
yeah well it's possible I guess either
way and hurt like hell like that would
not be fun twice the same thing make her
stop maybe move like she's a man anyway
so there you have it I guess it's time
for a break
hmm yeah that was quick why was that so
fast because of the ferry the first
start a few minutes late so we're not
quite at the half all right well let's
just get to the rake and then when we
come back we're gonna talk about filthy
Frank and the apocalypse 2.0 this is a
great scoop you do not want to miss we
were be back after this short commercial
break
ask yourself this very important
question is your underwear making you
happy at this very moment or were you
not even thinking about your underwear
wouldn't it be nice wearing worse that
is so soft it makes you feel like you're
making love to a cloud yes literally
putting your dick in a cloud that's what
they're putting the image of my mind and
that's a beautiful beautiful thing to be
doing this underwear is so soft me
undies that it makes Bob Ross yes the
beloved painter's voice sound like
Gilbert Gottfried's they wrote that
that's there a lot but they are so soft
that Kenny G thinks about them to get
inspired to write his next song yes it
is that soft because they use the
coveted micro modal fabric which is
three times softer than cotton take that
big cotton you can get the Frick out not
only will you feel your loins being
hugged by joy itself Mia
these gives you multiple style options
for both men and women you get to choose
between classic colors adventurous
prints prints like significant otters or
plant babies or shamrocks to commemorate
our favorite Irish holiday where we all
get drunk and cheat on our significant
others and get in fights I don't I'm
just saying I suppose that's what people
do when they drink I don't drink be that
as it may
we're taught we're here for the
underwear it's soft and even if you do
mess up and cheat on your significant
other you will be consoled by a
beautiful beautiful soft underwear
that's like making love to a cloud me
Andes has a great offer for our
listeners for any first-time perk just
when you order me an EZ get 15% off and
free shipping that's a no-brainer you
get 50% for free a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
if you doubt this just give it a shot
because you've got nothing to lose to
get 50% off your first pair of free
shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go to me Andes cops
Association this way these cops last h3
me Andes calm /h Lee you got nothing to
loose put your dick and balls in this
thing and tell me it doesn't change your
life there are very few products that I
can say actually changed my life that
are a paradigm shift ring is genuinely
one of these products I have six of them
around our house six of them what they
are are live motion detectors and alarm
I have a doorbell so someone comes ring
the doorbell you see them they're still
bring a package coming to tell you sweet
nothings coming to put believe dog poop
on your porch and let it on fire
whatever it is for better or worse you
know exactly what happened with sound
and here's what's special you can come
back and talk to them and be like hey
get that dog shut off my porch you punk
I got your face on camera I'm gonna tell
your parents boom you see him you could
talk to him here's the best part
it saves the incidents and it uploads to
the cloud so let's say some criminal
thug it comes up and smashes the ring
because he doesn't want to be seen it's
too late it's on the internet it blasts
it up to the cloud and you can review it
anytime that's why I've got six of them
all around my house because there's no
shenanigans you know everything that's
going on this product is incredible it's
reliable you could talk you could blast
them with the siren I mean guys it's
ridiculous it notifies you when someone
approaches then okay
you can control the sensitivity you can
control the distance it's ridiculous you
guys this technology is putting alarm
companies out of business because it's
so much better and cheaper we had we got
video of some creep jumping our fence
last like a couple weeks ago at like
2:00 a.m. we woke up in the morning we
saw this fricking creep cruisin around
in our back yard he walked all the way
around I think when he saw the ring and
he got blasted by the floodlight he was
like cooking out peace but we saw his
face we sent it to the police we put it
on the ring app there's a neighbor app
where everyone gossips and shares all
the gossip in the neighborhood it's
incredible
I cannot endorse ring enough it makes me
feel safe and it makes me feel connected
to my neighbors I cannot endorse this
product enough I absolutely love it
so for all of our listeners you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and a motion-activated flood
like camera the starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home just
go to ring.com slash h3 that's ring.com
slash h3 welcome back everyone we've got
a lot to talk about today so let's just
let's just get right the app into it so
ad pocalypse 2.0 guys everybody's
pulling their ads again and here we are
in this familiar place it's like you
when you know when you've had like a
nightmare and you're like wow I've
dreamt this before
mm-hmm and it feels familiar in a way
yeah that's what I apocalypse 2.0 is so
the genesis of this was this guy Matt's
what is and he made a video that
appeared on Reddit now when I opened
reddit this day it was like number one
it already had like 50,000 points in
like 20 minutes or something crazy and I
was like oh my god I knew immediately I
was like this is not gonna be good and
ended up getting like 200,000 points
it's like the number one video on on
reddit videos it's called YouTube is
facilitating the sexual exploitation of
children and being monetized 100 is that
a derp 181,000 now
I'm not going to show the video I'll
play it because the sound is all this
important the guy honestly shows a lot
of like nasty [ __ ] yeah I don't watch it
well it's hard because he show he's
showing the content and it's like
basically what I'll give you the
breakdown let's say you go to a video
about gymnastics okay
so eventually the sidebar will recommend
one with the underage girl on the thumb
though so once you click that then
YouTube starts recommending more of
these videos yeah and then when you
click one more then it's like all
underage girls but those videos are just
kids uploading or family and it's
whatever like home video stuff just
regular exactly right yeah but what's
happening is that in the comments these
creepy pet of
our time stamping parts like he showed
one like where their legs are open or
you can see up their pants I mean it's
truly repulsive [ __ ] dude leaving really
disgusting comments doing [ __ ] like
trying to get them to do challenges
where like it's just repulsive okay
really nasty stuff so the guy did good
work and exposing something that really
does need to be addressed with them um
within YouTube and let me just play a
snip of his video I won't put it on the
screen like I said because it has pity
point out well it's like up skirts on
eight-year-old girls I don't want to
show that ya know I'm not saying do a
softcore pedophile ring softcore on
YouTube yeah that's a good way to
describe here pedophiles are trading
social media contacts they're providing
links to actual miles porn in YouTube
comments
they're trading unlisted videos and see
great post home and YouTube's algorithm
through some kind of glitch or error in
its programming is actually it's not a
glitch or an error that's where you got
it gets that wrong the algorithm is
almost a victim of its own success it's
so smart
it's so good at what it does there most
of the time the people that make the
algorithm don't even know what it's
doing it has one prime objective which
is to keep people on the website as long
as possible so there may be a pattern it
discovered of people clicking through
these videos and then clicking those
ones and they watch them all and so the
algorithm knows like hey when you click
it doesn't have a moral judgment it
doesn't have a moral compass it just
knows hey when you click a video of a
little girl doing gymnastics then the
likelihood that you're gonna watch this
other video of little girls plagued
whatever you're gonna watch that whole
video - mm-hm and so he's right when you
click they changed it now but I did test
it at the time and he's right it only
took a couple clicks and then all the
sudden it was all real nasty [ __ ]
disturbing - like there was a lot of
times that's just how it works like you
said innocently it just recommends you
what you're watching so it's just
logical that it is logical that the
algorithm would do that yeah and and I
do give YouTube the credit of the doubt
in that I mean technically there's
nothing wrong with the content it starts
right it's just home videos that
families or kids are uploading the
content itself is finest exactly it's
these innocent sweet kids that don't
know any better and so this guy and a
lot of people were calling for all these
videos to be removed completely and it's
like well you're punishing these yeah so
we edit said kids I mean you know but
but at any rate what was I talking about
awesome I trained I thought
um about the algorithm so the algorithm
you were saying that it it got it wrong
that it's not an error right it's
definitely as working as intended and so
it's it's so hard for you there so
people you know when I see videos like
this and the guy is hysteric you know
he's just he's absolutely hysterical
just you gotta understand the scope of
YouTube you know is it really YouTube's
responsibility to like the solution now
is to UM close the comments so that
these dudes can't like timestamp and be
creepy and share contacts and all this
[ __ ] which is fine but is it really
YouTube's job to kind of like police
that this this much I mean the parents
need to bear some responsibility I if I
had like a eight-year-old daughter I
wouldn't let her have total immunity and
I would see what the hell who like a lot
of these videos had a lot of you as an
adult why don't you have a look at the
comments and yeah remove a couple or be
like dude you're not posting videos here
anymore yeah this is [ __ ] weird but a
lot of the videos had way more views
than they would ever just finally have
like two little girls doing a the
gymnastics challenge there's nothing
there's just two little girls having fun
there's nothing inherently really
entertaining that warrant these videos
having hundreds of thousands of views
yeah but so they did they had some of
them had upwards of millions of views
it's like why who what other purposes
are Washington yeah I think a large
responsibility is on these parents that
just let their kids go upload whatever
they want and just think you know you
gotta especially the internet I mean for
Christ's sake it's the Internet we all
know that mm-hmm
you need some you need to protect your
kids from the frickin internet so what
was the guy suggesting well first though
he suggested that we remove it all
that's not well if you want to have a
policy of like hey you can't post videos
if you're under 12 but it crazy it's
like why why are we doing this to
appease just because there's some creepy
dudes we're gonna like no that's a
complete extreme unnecessary so then
they had a policy that they would
disable comments already but it wasn't
working that good because a lot of
videos he showed the comments weren't
disabled some of them were so now
they're disabling comments on a lot of
these videos which is fine but again
it's just like cuz you I saw him also
mentioning like sponsors and making it
this whole thing but that's when he in
my opinion took it in a really bad
direction yeah and I really don't like I
really don't like the direction it took
I'm gonna play you a soundbite here
here's a comment he left on that reddit
thread he said I also have evidence that
some of the videos are being monetized
this is significant because YouTube's
got into very deep water two years ago
over exploitive videos being monetized
this event was dubbed the ad pocalypse
in my video I show several examples of
adverts from big-name brands like Lysol
and GLAAD being played before videos
where people are time-stamped in the
comments section I have the raw footage
of these adverts being played on
inappropriate videos as well as a
separate evidence video I'm sending to
all news outlets so he's he's almost
saying first of all what is wrong with
ads being on these little girls video
and because that guy's commenting don't
negate that that's my point - like why
shouldn't there be ads on this video and
certain innocent video there's nothing
wrong with the video itself like the
fact that some creeps are taking the
video and living gross comments on it
that's something else so he's he's he's
not explaining himself he's only saying
it's significant because YouTube's got
into deep water before so now I'm
sending it to a it's like you have no so
now I'm starting [ __ ] again because I
can't really that's kind of the
sentiment I'm getting just because I can
and it's not the same before they had
they had ads generally across YouTube
with very little very little curating
they had ads on like Isis recruiting
videos and they had ads on all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] so in that case there was a
lot more merit yeah but now it's like oh
people are commenting on videos of
little girls so it's ad pocalypse 2.0
and sadly it were a lot of brands pulled
out tons of brands pulled out but I just
loved this guy he's like okay I'm gonna
screenshot your video on this girl's
video I'm a screenshot your ad Disney on
this girl's video and I'm gonna and I'm
gonna send it to the news outlets
it's like bro he's doing exactly what
the media companies did in the first at
pocalypse to do as much damage to
YouTube as possible without even except
this time he doesn't even have a
legitimate reason is because last time
they somewhat had just because he can
really and you brought attention to this
problem and that's great but the whole
brand angle was so unnecessary here I
have a bunch of time stamps of him
talking about it here let me play by the
way he goes I'm gonna find an ad right
now he clicks through 20 videos there's
nothing there's no ads YouTube is not
monetizing this content and the only
thing he finds here I'll show you guys
cuz I don't want to show his video there
you have it adverts what he shows is
what more to go why is it doing that
okay you see that comfy leather shoes
50% off it's not even a pre-roll it's
some sidebar
weird [ __ ] that's the only ad he found
in like 20 clicks in his video just on
the page yeah I don't even know what
that it's not even a name-brand it's
some weird [ __ ] on the sidebar literally
above the recommended videos on the
sidebar so again I find because he says
he found the ads on all these major
brands he didn't show any evidence of
that in the video all he said was comfy
leather shoes 50% off
and he shows himself clicking through so
so many videos I'm not gonna show it
because it's really disgusting
the content that he shows in his video
now I I got a question and I don't I
don't even think this but just to play
devil's advocate for a second do you
think maybe he did that because he felt
that YouTube wouldn't actually do
anything about her take action unless
they're financially threatened by
getting advertising me to pull out like
maybe he just thought that that was the
one way that he could actually get them
to act on this well it's possible he
thought that but it's not a good reason
to go on his rationale is it's almost
dishonest to take that route and that is
the route he took because he's saying
you are in doing something inherently
wrong by showing these ads on this
videos and you should know better
because who's making money from those
ads the little girls who aren't doing
anything wrong the what does it matter
the pedophiles are making money if the
ads were there or not it wouldn't change
anything the guys are in the comments
let's say he didn't find any ads on any
of the videos it wouldn't change the
fact that these pedos are in the
comments doing what they're doing
it doesn't affect this story at all it's
dishonest way to get attention it's not
it's just not real I'm sure that is what
he was thinking then but again before it
was like Oh Isis is making video money
nice is is making money or these weird
pedo freaking creepy content guys had
ads and they were making money who's
making money who's getting these as
these little girls these innocent sweet
kids who are minding their own business
mm-hmm so do you think if do you think
YouTube would have taken care of this
without that they are constant but oh so
so it is something they're constantly
working on clearly they weren't doing
enough right because this guy was able
to find this and but I think the story
is big be cut not because of the brands
the story is big because of what he
found the whole brain thing the thing to
me is that you got to understand how
subtle these things are and like there's
only so much you can expect of YouTube
to be
right on top of it immediately I'm sure
they were doing a lot of this work
already but maybe not enough well but it
takes time to notice something that it's
a comment on a video sure right now it's
a comment with a timestamp it could look
completely innocent of millions of
videos that are uploaded every day
yeah million comments left on YouTube
per second yeah I guess that YouTube
this people up at YouTube that have
influence over the company is very small
a number of inner circle of people they
have triage they address the critical
things that they see as the most urgent
so when this guy makes his video and
then it becomes this whole media circus
all the sudden that becomes the top of
the pile of triage because they have to
address this issue that that now is more
urgent than it was before doesn't mean
it wasn't on their list or maybe they
didn't know it was so severe but there
their resources are limited and they're
always working towards something right
there right he just move it to the top
of the pile which is fine
but I think this story would have held
on its own completely because people
aren't people are not talking about oh
there was ads on it that are not central
to the story at all no it's not material
at all I mean he doesn't even bring it
up to like six minutes in people are
captivated by the fact that this how
nominal is recommending these videos one
after the other that's the that's the
thrust of this story and to me it's
interesting I didn't even imagine that
that was going on with people commenting
timestamps of weird moments and this
whole yeah it was a fact he did a great
job reporting that yeah I think he did a
good public service and I think YouTube
would appreciate even the the attention
because now they they know of a problem
and they'd they're addressing it right
they're doing a lot now the thing is
people it's so funny people are so weird
with YouTube they they expect YouTube to
be utterly perfect there's nothing like
it in existence nothing a place that you
can come post whatever you want get paid
for it
you don't have to pay anything you don't
it's totally free and then they say
these people get so outraged
like dude do you know how complicated
that is the idea like a lot of times
there are legitimate reasons to be upset
you too it's just annoying when someone
does it for the wrong reason it's like
you just delete itemizing everything
else you know I love that he's trying
simultaneously to be a youtuber and to
destroy YouTube a same time you know
it's just you can only expect what do
you have any idea that how can okay
YouTube operates beyond country
boundaries they have to deal with
copyright law they have to deal with big
media they have to deal with the legal
issues of every different jurisdiction
every different country that YouTube
appears on on the Internet they all have
different laws and regulations they have
to have policies that regulates so many
different things that's why I always
hear people talking about making YouTube
competitors and in theory it sounds so
simple and it's such so great and so
easy dude you haven't no freaking idea
how insanely complicated it would take
an Elon Musk to make something that way
another Multi multi like a really really
unusual you need a genius and you need a
genius team and lots of fun tons of
money tons and tons and tons of money so
I do think that YouTube deserves a lot
more slack than I guess because it's so
hard to appreciate the magnitude of what
they do and and how much goes into
making this ridiculous platform even
possible to begin with where we all make
a living them for Christ's sake
you know they give us 50 percent of the
ads it's pretty crazy actually 55
percent yeah I always thought that was
interesting 55 percent dude come on yeah
um so let me let me play an excerpt
again from this guy there you have it
adverts comfy leather shoes now this
video there are no timestamps and he
kind of disproves himself when he finds
that
there's no timestamps there's only two
comments on it so how is youtube
supposed to know that this video
shouldn't be monetized there's no signal
I still don't think that it shouldn't be
monetized I disagree with that point
right completely but yeah sure exactly
that even is debatable
there could be it was only uploaded a
little while ago but I have multiple
examples of big name brands we're
talking dodge ram disney in one video
showing a furniture company in another
where they're adverts are appearing on
videos where pedophile where people
users are time stamping the girls in
compromising positions one of the other
things that I want to point out with
these video we're now liable for the
comments I mean that's the central point
right it's like a legal precedent US
content creators are now liable for the
comments in our videos and that will get
us to monetize like come on now these
kids now if you have and how do you do
you really have to check every each and
every comment cuz a comment is just a
timestamp you know any timestamps all
looking at it it looks like anything of
course so who's gonna put so much time
and let's check in each and every
comment I assumes that because the
algorithm has detected this pattern that
a human has as well or that they even
have a way because there's probably
millions of these kinds of videos so
just because the algorithm is kind of
putting a thread between them doesn't
mean that there's any way for them also
to know which ones are the bad ones
which ones need to be demonetized
it doesn't mean that even humans have a
way just because the algorithm has a
common thread doesn't mean that a human
can go in there and look at nine years
string doesn't mean that at all they
don't even necessarily speak to each
other so right like you said it's not
even really about the videos it's about
the comments yes exactly and that's
that's that's oh nice so you know I
would understand if YouTube was like you
know if you're under 12 or 13 we're not
going to monetize your videos and that
when you turn 13 you have to send your
parents consent
but again you it's like how many
regulations the regulations are mounting
up and who's causing it youtubers
because they want to be outraged and get
a bunch of you know what I'm saying
it's like a simultaneous being like
YouTube is [ __ ] creators and then
being like YouTube we need more
regulations to [ __ ] creators so here
I've got more excerpts and if there
weren't ads on those videos those groups
would still be there that's my whole
point
there's the ads have literally nothing
to do with the story mm-hmm
if Disney if Disney pulls their ads
they're creeps are still there what does
did like what does Disney have to do
with someone commenting on a video give
me a freaking break I'm sending that
report out to every news outlet that I
possibly can and I'm hoping that people
will do the same the test is out
yourself go try it yourself go up in a
private window one more thing that I
want to show is now that I've been
looking at all this stuff once I go back
to the main YouTube page you can now see
how like look at how by the way just
because it's showing a bunch of kit like
here let me show you he's like I went
back on the homepage dude just because
you're watching a bunch of videos of
kids doesn't necessarily mean you know
you could if you're a kid you might be
watching other kids videos you are what
yeah exactly you know watching my videos
so again it's like I don't know it's so
over the top you know so it's just so
ridiculous
so now YouTube's been forced to super
overreact so now if there's
inappropriate comments they'll going to
D monetize your video and there's tons
of good good channels that are now their
whole channels their comments are being
turned off and their videos are being
demonized like if you have parents and
their kids and videos and this whole
thing their channels are being let's say
you destroyed genre
Oh legitimate you know families making
content together so it's a whole thing
yeah and then there's tons of brands
pulling out I just like to be like why
oh because there was inappropriate
comments on a video my ad showed on what
what what are we gonna turn off all
comments across all the platform it's
just so stupid the story is good the
story is good you don't have to make it
you know he he got so hysterical about
the brand's it's like that was so so
beside the point secondary yeah wasn't
even any dairy was zero you know here's
another thought though I mean and I'm
just playing devil's advocate here but
again the issue here is the commoners
not the content creators and so is there
anything YouTube can do to address that
side of it I mean they've created an
environment where people feel safe just
openly making creepy comments on it like
nothing's gonna happen to those
commentaries because they're anonymous
and there's no real way to figure out
look it's a it's a comments threat it's
the internet dude right you can either
be a parent and [ __ ] watch your kids
remove comments don't be so [ __ ] lazy
and just put your kid in front of
YouTube and assume that they're gonna
raise your kid disable the comments
right or don't let your kid on or erase
them or just [ __ ] accept that the
Internet's weird and when you put an
eight-year-old out there you're gonna do
weird [ __ ] the biggest right
welcome to the so basically the
alternative is like scorched earth where
now YouTube's been forced to disable ads
and comments on a ton of video just so
they can prevent the times when dudes
like creepy comments on videos and
advertisers get angry or I don't even
know what because this guy's hysterical
it's the internet dude there's all kinds
of creepy [ __ ] YouTube is the internet
that's what it is man you know let's
just acknowledge that
and then there was this whole hysteria
over YouTube kids app so this stuff
wasn't on the kids app I want to make
that clear I wasn't okay yeah it was not
but our next story is about the youtubes
kids app and that's when we come to our
dear beloved friend filthy Frank I saw
this I think Zack sent me this actually
I was like oh my god this is the
funniest [ __ ] I ever seen in my life
someone on the kids app was taking
filthy Frank's green screen like he did
made a video where he just did a bunch
of Goofy's in front of a green screen
so one of these wise guys took a bunch
of clips from that and was putting it in
the middle of kids videos and one of
these moms saw it and they just got
totally hysterical and they made a video
and they wrote a story and they sent it
all to all the news agencies saying
their secret messages encouraging my
kids to kill themselves thank God and
she's like well here let me read this
warning this article features disturbing
content and mentions of suicide video
promoting self-harm tips sliced between
clips of a popular video game has
surfaced at least twice on YouTube Wow
at least twice billion videos and
YouTube kids since July dude that's like
a year according to a pediatrician and
mom who discovered the video the suicide
instructions are sandwiched between
clips from the popular Nintendo game
splatoon and delivered by a man speaking
in front of what appears to be a green
screen and a parent effort to have him
blend in with the rest of the animated
video how no Farias he said remember
kids side ways for attention long ways
for results the man says mimicking
cutting motions on his forearm ended
something sinister when you read it this
man featured is filthy Frank who has
over 6.2 million subscribers and calls
himself the embodiment of everything a
person should not be although there's no
evidence that Frank whose real name is
George Miller was involved in creating
the doctored video he did not
immediately respond to CBS News for
requests for comment
obviously it wasn't him like in their
mind or like he made the video and it's
a conspiracy to make my kids kill
themselves like dude he did not
immediately respond yeah
where is fun at all what does that mean
immediately George Miller we have a
media request are you splicing yourself
in the middle of kids videos to
encourage them to kill themselves answer
immediately oh nice
when free has found the video on YouTube
last week she posted it on her blog here
this is the video of her getting all
moms a girl I have the video let's watch
let's enjoy this reminds me of the man
who found the North Norfolk it'd to kill
himself lady you know now the guy who
added this is a [ __ ] more yeah it's
not funny and it's just really stupid
but my god you have to be equally dumb
to watch that and be like this is there
see to have our kids kill them freakin
Sherlock Holmes on YouTube at four
minutes 44 seconds shows a man slicing
sliced into showing children how to
properly slit their wrists protect our
children this is not okay parents demand
action here you're lazy you're lazy
idiot just don't sit your [ __ ] kids in
front of YouTube and act like that's a
babysitter or don't expect better from
well kids app shouldn't have that stuff
I agree
but it's usually but then
they still if you want to be safe put on
a Barney DVD you gotta check where I am
like you they're gonna end up in front
of Moe and et doing spider-man and Elsa
likes humping each other
yes if you want it to be safe put on a
Barney DVD otherwise expect that you're
there's some weird [ __ ] on you too I
mean for Christ's sake lady take some
responsibility
you know YouTube's doing the best it can
there's a [ __ ] trillion videos I'm
curious what's gonna happen with our kid
when they start yeah I'll probably the
thing is that I hear is that kids just
love that [ __ ] oh yeah my god it's like
when they're in front of a screen
they're just hypnotized it's like you
can't even talk to them they don't hear
you
it's crazy I've seen my nephew it's a
saint as a parent I can imagine there's
so many times when you're like I just
need this kid to be distracted and I
need I just I need this I don't know if
you've seen it but it's like scary
they're they're just hypnotized and you
can talk to them they don't even respond
interesting so I'm sure that our kid
will enjoy YouTube but I don't I'm not I
don't expect you to be a perfect place
it's it's like these people that love it
and depend on are also the ones trying
to kill it they're like oh yeah my kid
watches YouTube ten hours a day but I
saw one thing that's inappropriate so
I'm gonna mess with all their sponsors
now this was this incident on the
YouTube kids app or one one this one
this one was on the kids I mean I feel
like there's a little bit more leeway to
be upset about that cuz I mean I agree
overtly saying hey this is safe for kids
you know I agree but dammit how do you
detect that ya know I mean obviously
it's it's difficult but we avail them
you can't hold him accountable a little
bit on that one I am NOT denying that
this one is obviously worse but still as
the parent well first of all the guy who
that's why I say the guy who netted that
in is a [ __ ] douche bag yeah sure
yeah and he should have his account
deleted and the mom too I mean she
doesn't know I mean we're all super
familiar with filthy Frank video and we
know what it is but to heard like if you
had zero context that would
be creepy as [ __ ] to see that show up on
your kids video you know I think it's a
little hysterical to think that there's
a conspiracy to have our kids commit
suicide yeah that's probably a little
bit of a reaction it's just you gotta
understand if you're gonna put your kids
in front of it
and you come across one weird video yeah
Millions
Oh little kid don't watch this one let
me put on something else for you it's
like it's just right you gotta be that
curator you don't you don't have the
control you're trusting YouTube to
curate content made by thousands of
different people thousands of different
videos [ __ ] that you don't know what's
in it you don't know what's gonna pop up
YouTube says yeah we do we do our best
to make sure it's all appropriate for
kids but again this is a platform that's
run by algorithms they don't watch these
videos it's literally impossible there's
millions of them
so you are trusting YouTube to entertain
your kid which is fine but you have to
understand the Machine okay it's not
putting them in front of a burning DVD
with a and a controlled environment
where you know exactly what they're
saying it's [ __ ] there's millions of
YouTube's YouTube videos and millions of
different people this guy just has a
shitty sense of humor I would imagine um
and he should have his account removed
you know and I and I'm not saying that I
don't I don't get it but again I think
the parents need to accept that look
yeah this is not a perfectly controlled
environment they try their best but
regardless I thought it was just so
funny that like of all people to see
yeah and hot water George was always
very upfront about what his content is
yeah he's not true he's not trying to
pretend to be anything he's not George
just felt that Parker's a cop it's
pocalypse before anyone even knew what
it was yes it was always demonetized
that's right yeah before anyone was he
was the original he never made money one
time he showed me his analytics how much
he earned on a ton of views and I was
like I took my breath away I felt so bad
for the guy because I'm the same and one
of yous what it is oh no yeah totally on
the same amount of views we were making
like five times more and we weren't even
making like our CPMs were way
worse than some of my other friends so
when I saw that I was just like oh oh it
hurts so bad so I you know yeah
so in short filthy Frank is running a
conspiracy to to have our kids commit
suicide by the way are our parents
assuming that kids just watch that and
they're like oh I'm gonna kill myself I
was thinking about that does a
five-year-old even understand about a
course yeah that's why as the parent you
saw this okay close it and don't play
this video I'd be like oh man they're
like oh [ __ ] now this razor that I found
I'm gonna know how to use it I'm gonna
kill myself now ridiculous come on we
all just need to chill out it's [ __ ]
ridiculous dude who made the video needs
to chill mom who needs the video needs
to chill YouTube the VEVO Road article
needs to chill everyone needs to chill
the CBS News ela you need to chill I
need to chill that's for sure Theodore
you need to chill Theodore needs to
chill he's been kicking you kicking your
ass
he'd always been kicking a lot Neela's
uh every morning when I wake up is like
he's moving a lot I don't know if that's
normal I think probably or maybe he's
just a super athlete he's got the
genetics like a dad
yeah look is that three months away from
having that baby by the way three months
before that kid's gonna be sitting
another one on the YouTube kids at you
know three months man we we we crazy
[ __ ] so there you have it folks I hope
that was informative
there you have it so make sure to let
all the advertisers in the world know
that that YouTube is not a safe place
for them do you think it's sustainable
that we'll be able to continue being
anonymous on the internet over the long
term like 50 years from now is that
gonna stick around that element of it it
feels like so many of these problems you
know are related to that like these
commenters or the people posting these
videos well how do you even
you know I don't know how you heard it
even I'm just curious we think like I
have no idea
IIIi I have no idea I really like this
problems are not as big as they seem and
it's over exaggerated yeah so I mean
there are plenty other places on in this
planet that that you it's much more
difficult if not impossible to be
anonymous on the Internet you know what
I mean that even on YouTube
I believe so I'm not super knowledgeable
of this so but I gather there leaving
comments that's not a crime
yeah but say like in South Korea for
example I believe in South Korea to get
an internet connection you it's like
registered to your equivalent of your
Social Security card essentially very
interesting and so you know your real ID
kind of follows you around the internet
so if you say or do something you know
it's pretty easy to track it back to you
I'm sure there's a way to circumvent it
as there is for anything right but you
know it's not like here where you know
you just create an account and if you're
using a VPN I mean you're you know 98%
of the time covered like nothing's gonna
happen to you I think that's a very comp
I really I need to think about that I
have no idea I really think it's just
with social media and everyone having
like immediately the platform to create
a crazy story
just wait waiting it out or making a
video it's just that it it can really
over exaggerate stuff and I think people
are gonna learn to put it in perspective
and write be more learn to trust your
intuition when something is a problem
and something something is not I don't
know it's like what we had we had to
learn how to deal with criticism and
like all the negative comments and you
understand that it's really a loud
minority it really is it's not
representing of the majority so well
it's something like I don't know it's
just that I mean this this is just one
person and she's able to tweet it out
and now there's an article about on the
news right I don't know anything about
her guy whom started
whole thing with two one you know
200,000 likes I'm ready he's a super
small Channel yeah like a thousand
subscribers yeah
and he's just a dude talking into a
webcam I mean anybody on earth could
make that video I don't know though Dan
I really I don't know would would that
change the behavior of people well like
these these guys in the comments in the
gymnastic video or whatever I mean they
obviously feel comfortable just kind of
openly being a pedophile on YouTube
which isn't even like an underground web
site and you know like we said I mean
it's like what do you do about that we
they could be anywhere they could be
anybody there's you know not gonna I
have a feeling that people need to
accept that there's just sometimes not
things you can do yeah we don't need to
do something about everything some
things don't you know what I'm saying
it's just that now you see everything
before you wouldn't like there's just
the world is by far a much safer nicer
it is comfortable place than ever before
it's just that a lot more [ __ ] is
visible yeah yeah totally I mean we
can't fix every goddamn thing and not
it's not like this is human trafficking
this is just some nasty comments
it's disgusting it is it's really
disgusting but it's not human
trafficking right killer yes thank makes
me worried
no anyway anyway so that's that that's
my heartache guys I'm gonna give you
update last episode at the end I said I
was gonna go buy some legal marijuana
and I did do that and I mostly
experienced yeah smooth that [ __ ] up
dawg
it was awful let me tell you this place
in Woodland Hills I'd had really good
reviews I roll up to it we went to get
it right off to the podcast it looks
like you know downtown when you're right
driving around downtown and there's like
a huge parking lot and it's closed with
like barbed wire and a gate so that's
how I'm greeted that's what it is it's a
gate is open and it's a big parking lot
with barbed wire said wow this is just
already weird
and there's like a big medical red cross
so I walk in and then there's a lady
behind it looks like a bank teller but
in a subway station in terms of
cleanliness so you walk in and there's
glass and this little receptacle so she
goes I need your IDs well first of all
she didn't say anything I'm like so uh
I'm here to buy weed you know I don't
the [ __ ] going on she goes okay I need
both your IDs before you can go in I
don't even know there's anywhere to go
in because I'm just standing and this
looks like the men in black entrance and
then some shady dudes well code
super weird dudes all some guy looks at
me I was like you got a nice size oh my
god some guy started hitting on HeLa
right away he goes What did he say to
you or you got a nice nose it's
something else that was really creepy
I don't remember anyway so I we gave her
idea to this girl and then she buzzes
open a door and we walk in and it looks
like a super ghetto head shop there's
just like mason jars of weed the dude
behind the counters reminds me of my
drug dealer in high school and for some
reason where there was a dude behind the
counter yeah there was two dudes behind
the food's you went to you went to the
wrong place wait there's not a dude
behind your counter how do you not have
a deal it's every weed shop I've ever
been to it's like hot chicks what yeah
they were not they were far favored I
mean that would have been the first big
red flag to me is like oh it's not like
a tattooed hot chick with dreadlocks
this guy came to the wrong place looks
like two dudes that might mug me as soon
as I saw the entrance I thought we were
at the wrong place like I had him at
when I heard that weed is legal and I've
been hearing about it from our friends
when they go and buy stuff I imagine
like concierge like the Mack shop like
yeah like when you go to the Apple shop
all right why--it's and beautiful and
say I got this professionals with like a
belt on it uh yeah I thought it was
gonna be like that no these guys look
like they were gonna meet me outside and
rob me they were gonna sell me the
weight and then rob me when I walked
outside so
it felt still somehow like I was
committing a crime then that was the
thing that struck me I was like it feels
like I'm doing something wrong
you gotta believe your ID and walk
through a few doors so technically it is
a crime still what it's like it's not
legal federally this is all like a weird
great saying technically you are doing
something illegal so I wanted to get one
of these vape pens that had like 14 CBD
to one THC they don't have any pens I
was like are you [ __ ] those what do
you got
they had their inventories very low so I
end up getting this tincture which is
like an oil dropper that has 14 CBD to
one THC it looks good oh man it looks
like someone just made this in their
living room I swear that's not like
slick labeling it's like I don't know No
then I go okay here's my card oh we
don't take card you don't take cash all
right dude
well we have a we have an ATM over here
I'm like okay looks like a ATM did like
steal your identity
yes yes okay so I get a hundred bucks
out and I'm like this guy's gonna mug me
if I don't buy wave so I buy the
tincture I go home I take one tincture
hit again this is like one
I guess milligram is that right then
that's like a mask as well as a dose as
it gets
yeah yeah and so I feel a little bit I'm
like alright let's [ __ ] go and I take
three big more tinctures and then I just
I just have to stop the one I had an
awful time I felt like [ __ ] but then I
tried a couple more times that I took
like one you know one hit and that but I
just I think you felt like saved the
whole weekend yeah
yeah I don't know I can't I just think
that I don't like it this is not for you
yeah that's why I was like man I'll take
one milligram like help come on but I
just gets me so anxious and I don't know
if it's a placebo like I expect to get
anxious so I make myself anxious you
know but I I have a theory that CBD oil
is a total is like total sugar pill Wow
you think it's like CBD to the
separation no but like people say CBD by
itself even without THC is like some
miracle drug I think that it's like you
might you're you'll get the same
medicinal effect as eating a tic-tac do
you know what I'm saying I I really not
sure I buy it and I'm sure I'm pissing a
lot of people often who are like CBD
cured my arthritis
there's CBD are so into it yeah it's
like the elected I got cancer man
they're like oh [ __ ] just rub some CD
CBD oil yeah I mean I don't think it
cures cancer but have you seen that
there are videos of people forget what
disease but um they have like severe
tremors and stuff like they can yeah I
I've heard that in it like legitimately
stops they were shaking yeah I mean it
it does some I've heard that it works
for seizure disorders and I'm not in the
place to I guess you know we're not
making I know yeah I can't stay I can't
make any claims but how it affects that
but it apparently what I read is that
it's good for like anxiety yeah right
it's like I'm like oh this is anxiety
yeah if CBDs good friends add and I'm
the [ __ ] Pope so what did you feel
like when you were on it um I feel
really dumb I just feel I feel like the
finally work I feel pathetic little
version of myself and I'm just laying
there and I feel like everything I say
stupid I feel like everything I'm saying
is uninteresting I feel like everything
I'm doing is something I wouldn't be
doing if I was sober and I get my head
I'm like would I be doing this if I was
sober you just started to think about
everything like I hope that's what
happens to me like I would get if we're
in
with people let's say and I need to get
up and pee mmm I wouldn't do it cuz I
thought if I'm gonna walk funny yeah or
like I just start to think about it for
an hour right like oh it's so awkward
than getting up to pee right now yeah
everyone's gonna be noticing me and
they're gonna know that I'm high it's
awful I hate it I'm probably gonna kick
something tonight
it was nice before bed actually the
thing is that I don't do it in the
evening yeah the thing is like I was
anxious about our new video by the way
our new videos out go check it out I put
so much freaking work into that be
really good I edited so much as well my
point I'm about to move on but my point
was that I was super anxious because I
had a ton of more work to do and I and
so I think it as that but there was
times on the weekend where I took it and
it was kind of nice
I don't know I'm working on it it's a
it's a work in progress but the new
videos out guys go enjoy it
a stress reproductions dot [ __ ]
comics reproductions it turned out
pretty funny that it was like it's a
really gross video so gross and we did
this year to premiere you can't skip the
video about that yeah they were like
trapped it's like Clockwork Orange
some people say afterwards this is the
last time I'm watching a video in the
premiere because yeah we ruined it
because usually they would skip through
whatever their watch yeah you guys I
really went all out for you guys I spent
each of those edits you see were there's
like two girls that go beast mode and I
spent a full like 10 hours 8 to 10 hours
on each chunk so that was 2 discs solid
days of work on each of those edits yeah
and then the last sketch we did I went
all out of work yeah yeah it was a lot
it was a lot of work that's what was
stressing me out because it was like I
knew I wanted to do all that stuff and
it's like when you see when you
just have the rough footage and you know
it's like looking at a piece of marble
and you know there's something inside
but there's you kind of work to get to
it and I'm like there's so much work it
can sometimes feel overwhelming but you
just got to take it one one cut at a
time but it feels very daunting at first
where you're just like oh man like how
do I even get to the center of this
thing but I enjoy it how it came out and
I hope you guys enjoy it's gross thing
cuz I was cracking up when I was heading
a lot of people said it was too gross to
watch and I understand that but I guess
my my measure of gross is different
because yeah I find it really gross but
hilarious too like I was cracking up
editing them and watching these women
are just so insane my goodness my
favorite part though has got to be let
me pull it up I'm not going to get a
copyright strike for showing my own
video I'm gonna copyright strike my own
[ __ ] I love on my own videos I show up
on the home page be dunking my head in a
bowl of pro by the way really I can't
believe they you all just lurk like you
went all in on that run you know I was
there let's get it done
hey good know it did I there's good
ranch in this bad ranch - that was one
of the bad room yeah that was the one
that's like super tanky and zesty and
it's just like not good but my favorite
part of all
[Music]
it took a long time to find the right
sounds to trebling but it came out good
but my favorite part is coming up here
when she pulls like a tapeworm out and
then sucks it call it it's a four ball
might be what all those sounds and
should I obviously put in the squishing
and everything this one took a while to
find the one that's about to play right
now oh yeah
the poling sound so look at this
dangling [ __ ] whatever it is she
pulls it out and that sucks on it look
at this yeah we actually recorded that
sound ourselves oh you're right it will
Foley yeah we love I mean I tell you I
looked for like an hour plus for the
right sound effect and was driving me
crazy were like [ __ ] it let's just do it
ourselves so we took like a yoga we took
a rope yeah and I put it my shirt and I
pulled it through like that that's right
I probably forgot that we did that
through Seligman cuz this mount is so
important like that scene is not the
same without that ya know that's what
makes it yeah we did do that as often
but I think my favorite of that it's I
actually really liked how the crap the
baby crabs right away trigger like a
genocide when she pulls her own face but
the next girl pulls her own face out of
the crab did you like when God speaks to
be loved or do this do you love get your
[ __ ] together this is the one I did
first and I was like man that was that
was really fun I liked it it's really
compelling so I wanted to do one near
the beginning as well and that was my
thought
process but here stir the waste of oh
god yeah this was shocking the amount of
meat that came out of the leg and I love
how she goes when she's taking a bite at
first he goes what is this and then she
eats it by the way there was a joke
about the first girl that she looks like
the villain from The Little Mermaid mmm
yeah but I was like is that can I say
that I feel like anymore you know I did
I know I did but we cut it off cuz we're
like I don't know if that's like
inappropriate I kind of little mean is
it an accurate though I mean she looks
like the freaking I think she's eating
seafood Ursula thank you if I had the
nerve I got this girl special character
though I love her so lowlifes are
another level she has a literally
another camera in the top yeah you
better keep these lobsters coming okay
yes she's amazing
by the way this is all butter that you
see in the the dipping bowls it's a
cutter it's like their own sauces that
they make she goes what is this
slowed-down what you know what I did I
took here
I took the what and I slowed it down to
50% and then I had to one where the
pitch shift is maintained or the pitches
maintain and then one where it's not
playtime over there you're not really
good nice tall flakes you like more lol
[Music]
and then you think it's over and this
sound came out really good works like
and then you know people complain about
Japanese whaling I love how she reacted
and she starts laughing and then of
course how can we forget the real oh gee
this is I can't watch this one got me so
excited when she look if there's more
Alfredo than there is freaking lobster
leg all the way down that's a legitimate
deep throat hmm
you like that damn I'm actually looking
away I can't watch this don't ya Ian
how'd you like the video Zach did you
love it tell me what you've [ __ ]
loved it man thank you that what is the
so it's a little ASMR but like I said
like I said in the video I really truly
think it's just other women that are
hungry and want to be eating I swear to
God go to the comments know that that
seems accurate in fact in the comment
for your video because I'm scrolling
through it and I saw one
girls say that but this is she she
professed it this is really sad but I
used to be anorexic and I would watch
these channels wow I really crushed the
craving essentially like vicariously wow
that's incredible huh so yes it's a lot
of that it's a lot of that women who
want to be eating who want to watch
people eating it's all women's
predominantly women [ __ ] fascinating
dark weather is this the dark way so
here we got this pizza that blew my mind
when I showed up the guy I we had to
open both of our front doors to fit it
in the house really yeah kind of over
ranch we can imagine it's really quite
foul yep there you have it that's our
new video well done thank you very like
right after you film it
the vegan place there was no meat on
that know that well by the way I'm not
vegan anymore
oh no that's been I'm over that right
Gila yeah but actually we've we've just
gone on like eating at home diet and I
think we're doing good diet where it's
just we're trying to just eat healthy a
salad with every meal fruit fruit just
not cuz we we would get busy a lot of
the times during the week would work and
then we would order food and I wouldn't
hang out and eat like you don't eat
healthy when you're eating out there's
just no way so we're so but I'm doing
well in low weight lossing yeah I'm not
vegan actually I got to tell you the
truth I went two weeks plus vegan I
gained weight no way yeah dude I swear
to God I was a tool like seven when I
started and two weeks later I was at 210
and I was like bro this is not work not
this is not working at all my goodness
but now you're actually I'm on the
decline
yeah done it like - OH - Ethan decline
he's in decline baby
what else there's a couple others to say
while we talk about you I like that go
on we that I want to I we released this
small little collection on today fresh
and I saw a lot of people liking it
today yes nice and I wanted to let them
know who designed it Teddy fresh calm so
this whole the longest time we call this
date and I bought collection because
Ethan designed it thank you so we
thought like what what is designer name
be just my middle name is Edward so was
lovingly called Ethan Edward in the
office thank you ela forgive me God like
a true designer the sketches are so
realistic it changed a lot since then
but I mean the socks the socks right on
one side color on the other mm-hmm long
sleeve there it is there's the long
sleeve yes man how about none I'm a true
genius thank you for your nice thank you
that long last people are acknowledging
me I really like that sweatpants a lot
from that collection you want a pair
yeah but this yogurt is part of it this
is like my favorite shirt ever it's it's
it's more pricey than almost shirts but
it's heavy cotton yeah it's hard to
appreciate how amazing it feels without
wearing it but it's like it's heavy its
oversized it just it's really flattering
it looks really good and it's just
really nice material but that's enough
about us there's a couple more stories I
wanted to get to I want to talk about
our Kelly I wanted to talk about ja Rule
I wanted to talk about Jesse wire and
but I'm also kind of over it till my
throat hurts well family gets really I
if I get sick again I'm gonna be so
[ __ ] pissed bro I was so you got
antibiotics too
no and I ate them all I didn't even stop
early but I last night my throat started
getting scratchy again oh just like it
happened before I was so sick last time
like I literally gotten I was set me
back like two weeks that's why we didn't
have a video for so long yeah
if I get sick again helo I'm gonna be so
[ __ ] pissed so I don't know maybe we
should wrap it up I really want to talk
about this stuff though but it's a lot
it's actually a lot to get to we're even
going an hour and a half
Oh YouTube D monetizes van tiebacks
videos the Jesse's small that thing the
guy who faked the hate crime draw Royal
bombing during the performance and our
Kelly and the bachelor of course maybe
we should talk about the bachelor a
little bit do we have a guest next week
because maybe I can talk about this
stuff next week not yet okay mm-hmm
everyone's like I know I'm to at least
quickly say publicly oh wow that's
pretty captivating little clickbait IRL
it's been hour and a half HeLa huh okay
so let's wrap it up let's call it a day
let's stop while we're ahead
are we ahead Oh No thank you
did you all have a good time in Zach did
you guys have a good time yes I did how
are how are you guys doing Ian how are
you doing someone I just want to say to
this guy who said tell Ethan to get that
hair off his shoulder that's from the
fairy sewed that hair got everywhere I
didn't got anything I've got it all over
me yes I'm hoping just imagine what your
lungs look like yeah Ian yeah how are
you talk to me good that's why you does
it sound like you're being ironic I got
a piece so bad Zac what about you good
I'm doing very well
submitted some more school applications
excellent good good good what's your
dream school us
USC huh university spoiled Chile my dad
is a die-hard UCLA fan and he would
probably remember what salt Bay did to
that sandwich well the funny thing is so
am i I love UCLA but how are you gonna
pay for that that's expensive right I
guess I asked you for a raise but you're
going gonna do two years because you're
at Community College no problem probably
like three yeah you want to major in
what are you majoring in probably
communications and then off to law
school law school you slick ass
[ __ ]
do you know what kind of you're gonna be
in so much I actually I remember Zach
told us that I was like you better not
[ __ ] sue me in ten years I can't
believe what will you have to go through
here with those prices of college oh man
you're gonna be so [ __ ] and then like
you have a loan for the rest of your
life like you're a good student you're
gonna you're gonna you'll prevail thank
you I appreciate it now you're a good
real good student I wrote you a letter
of recommendation did that work out for
you it was a beautiful letter thank you
very much
you didn't read it though no I didn't
yeah of course that would be unethical
yeah really
you know it's well if he read it he
wouldn't be thanking huh yeah if you if
you receive a letter of recommendation
you're not supposed to read it because
if what they write about you is is
secret cuz if you know and they write
something on flattering or you you know
that you're not supposed to interact
with what because this shouldn't affect
that would be such a don't obtain such a
stab oh my good someone's like yeah
right our commendation oh you're right
odd do not hire this person like no I
wouldn't write a letter without the
person reading
but can you but like traditionally
you're supposed to seal it I didn't know
that and then you deliver it directly so
that it it's not read by anyone but the
person you like seal it with wax so you
know if it's been opened you know you're
like zach is a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I
guess because otherwise you can just
fake a letter about yourself that is
that well it's corroborated I mean you
would have your contact info on it yeah
yeah but think thank you again for doing
your welcome Zach thank you for thank
you for flattering me yeah Dan how are
you I'm pretty good pretty good
what else what would take you to the
next level of very good or just good you
know I one of my best friend's is moving
out of town and we had his going-away
party last night so I'm a little bummed
about oh yeah that's a shame believe in
LA where is he going
to [ __ ] nowhere and like New Mexico
is why idiot is he selling meth yeah
he's going there because he's getting a
2-bedroom apartment for $400 a month
he's at a paying and I'm close to two
grand for a one-bedroom here smart guy
yeah exactly heard a lot of people are
moving out of California yeah no not
only because it's so a lot of my parents
have been leaving I don't know not only
is it's so expensive but that taxes here
are totally so brutal it's most it's
mostly the rent though like you're right
about the taxes that's on top everything
but the rent is it's it's a problem yeah
it's absurd I pay out the ass for my
place I mean if you can go get your own
place for $400 a month [ __ ] have no idea
know what we go through no none of these
stupid obnoxious older [ __ ] have any
idea I got to buy a house like two
dollars they know literally they bought
used to buy houses for under fifty
thousand dollars and for Los Angeles you
spend that in two years on a rent it's
like nothing two years
more like one year on rent if you have a
nice place that's a really nice that's a
really nice but dan says how much is
your red then it's about 2.5 a month and
I got a roommate split oh you split that
okay yeah yeah but you don't want to you
don't necessarily have a roommate when
you're and Dan I I mean you you make a
decent salary here I know I mean I'm the
guy that pays you so I know you know
yeah but like well I understand your
being economical but it's like God you
know you should if you're trying to live
with some put some money aside yeah do
you like living with someone Dan I do
prefer to have your own place I mean
yeah I prefer but that's it's not really
realistic honestly it's just it's a
waste of money yeah yeah you know when I
was in college in Santa Cruz
I paid over a thousand dollars to share
a room ooh Jesus
yes I'm Chris was so I found shared a
room with a friend and we're each paying
like 1,200 a month that's nuts
I'm I was a big rock but we shared I
when I came here like you know I didn't
have a lot of money and then we had to
find a job and pay rent and do all this
stuff and it's like what the [ __ ] I
think we were sharing a room we were
paying 800 a month or something yeah we
had yeah we wouldn't a housemate yeah
yeah we just had one house made but but
then we brought in someone to live in
the living room live on the couch that
took the pressure off yeah he was spent
he was paying like 500 a month to sleep
on the [ __ ] couch in the living room
I used to do that even like 5 years ago
we had somebody living in our living
room and two couples there's five people
in the - Wow
colleague you know I there when I was in
college I lived in a big house there was
three bedrooms and then one of their
friends is like I'm gonna move into the
living room and I'll just pay all the
utilities and I was like fine whatever
that's fine
we all agreed then when I move out the
dude didn't pay any of the freakin bills
oh and they were hit and I was dead
broke I was trying to find where
now when I was there ela just moved
there we're struggling to meet our own
rent and they're hitting me up like hey
our friend didn't pay the bills and so
there's huge late fees and you owe us
like 500 bucks to [ __ ] your credit what
wasn't on my credit was on his credit oh
but they were like hey you owe us money
because our friend didn't pay the
utilities and there was huge late fees
that did live there all year and we were
like months delinquent on all of our
bills I was like what and all that I
listen I can't I can't pay you for this
mm-hmm it's brutal brutal I think I
could give them a little money thank you
yeah yeah I gave him a couple hundred
bucks yeah
which was a lot fun I remember but I was
like what the [ __ ] your friend like goes
doing but you know everything was the
Wild West back then every dollar matters
yeah
[ __ ] well there you have it set it all
right again
absolutely what do you plan this week
getting in going to the bathroom you've
wiggling over here he's wiggling on
that's your plan for the for the weekend
I haven't give it much thought what am i
doing I don't know
gonna go lurk around that sounds weird
what the [ __ ] I'm not going to get into
details you don't want to know
apparently not no I don't keep that to
yourself
sorry I asked any Dan and Zach any plans
this weekend um probably just chill out
listen to some dead you know we're
making a shirt called the Grateful Dead
it's a play on a Grateful Dead design
probably gonna be playing some apex
legends yeah I've actually I'm into
Kingdom Hearts now I can't get the
Kingdom Hearts I'm enjoying it so I'm
gonna go play that hell yeah I'm trying
to play the new attached
oh the Battle Royale Tetris we don't
really understand it yeah I think so
yeah but you played once and you got six
place I was impressed mm-hmm all right
well let's wrap this up we've said it
all we've done it all
guys I thank you for coming and spending
this precious time on this earth we
don't have much of it but yet you chose
to spend it here with us and by golly
isn't that a nice thought I thank
everybody in the here Dan and Zac ela
and Theodore for coming by and in saying
what the eff is up I pay them to be here
but will not yield would you guys still
come here by choice even without the
money right yeah it's nice I appreciate
that
I gotta do something with those fur
suits but regardless guys have a magical
blessed weekend it's Friday TGI Friday
as they say Friday Friday everybody get
down with Friday is it music playing
damn yep
I'm so excited to just get in bed TGIF
thank God it's Friday everybody get down
with Friday
yeah TGIF thank God it's Friday we
should go to TGIF
no okay I learned recently like what
what does that help stand for Oh
International House of Pancakes
mind-blowing when you when you find out
Oh Mike that's why they flipped the pea
into the B in that whole media stunt
International House of burgers get real
I don't like that yeah get out of here
with that [ __ ] hi hub eye hub come on
give me a [ __ ] break
all righty I guess that's it I yes sir
songs almost over okay guys thanks for
watching we'll see you next week
watching bye everybody
[Music]
you